you had a question yeah the the question
I sent you earlier was about uh Matthew
16 wow okay repeat the question friend
so people can know what you're asking
yeah M specifically Matthew 16 uh 27 and
28 that's right specific passage okay
open up your Bible you have your Bible
ready yes yes yes okay what version do
you
read uh right now I have a ESV okay all
right go to Matthew 16 27-28 he's asking
me a question about this passage I've
answered before but remember we're
creatures of repetition we need to hear
something repetitively until it become
second nature by the grace and mercy of
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ okay
Matthew 1627 and 28 read it for me for
the son of man is going to come with his
angels in the glory of his father and
then he will repay each person according
to what he has done truly I say to you
there are some standing here who will
not taste death until they see the son
of man coming in his King Kingdom okay
now you're asking
me about Matthew 16:28 specifically
because there it's saying those that
were standing and hearing Jesus some of
them would be alive to see what read 28
again uh to see the uh the son of man
son of man com coming in his kingdom
okay so how is it that the Lord Jesus
said that those standing before him some
of them would still be alive when they
would see the son of man coming in his
kingdom that didn't happen
right that's what you're asking me oh no
yeah uh of course I believe uh yeah but
are you asking me that how to answer
that yes yes yes how to because you're
scaring me because Timmy was about to
answer for you Timmy was gonna answer so
let's repeat so people understand what
you're asking me so don't get confused
in Matthew 16:28 Jesus says truly I say
to you some of you standing here will
not see death until they see the son of
man coming in his kingdom
right but
Jesus went to heaven and his disciples
who were standing before him died and
that was 2,000 years ago 2,000 years
later
and Matthew 16:28 never took place right
yes that that is the objection I heard
from all right unbeliever right now the
answer is very simple I'm going to show
you Matthew Mark and Luke
recording Matthew Mark and Luke
recording the same statement right so
okay Matthew 1628 read it one more
time truly I say to you there are some
standing here who will not taste death
until they see the son of man coming in
his kingdom Now read the next chapter
Matthew 177 veres 1 and
two and after six days Jesus Took with
him Peter and James and John his brother
and led them up a high mountain by
themselves and he was transfigured
before them and his face Shone like the
sun and his clothes become became White
as light okay so notice after Jesus said
there are some of you standing here who
will not see death until you see the son
of man coming in his kingdom right yes
and then Matthew said say about seven
days later Jesus took some of them not
all the disciples he only took Peter
James and John on a high mountain right
on a high mountain and he was
transfigured before their eyes and he
started shining right his face Shone
with the brightness of the Sun and his
clothes became you know just dazzling
white now let's go to Mark
9 Mark 9 verses 1-
3 Mark 9 ver 13 I want to see if you see
the pattern here if you catch the
pattern Mark 9: 1-3 let's see if you're
catching the
pattern Matthew Mark Luke all record the
saying of Jesus and right when Jesus
says these words they all go on to
immediately Show Jesus took some on a
high mountain go ahead now Mark 9 verses
and3 and he said to them truly I say to
you there are some standing here who
will not taste death until they see the
kingdom of of God after it has come with
power and after six days Jesus Took with
him Peter and James and John and led
them up a high mountain by themselves
and he was transfigured before
them and his clothes became radiant
intensely white as no one on earth could
bleach them okay you got it it right yes
so does Mark agree with Matthew that
after the Lord Jesus said some of them
not all of them will see the kingdom of
God coming in glory the son of man
coming in the Kingdom about a week later
some of them not all of them Ma Peter
James and John was taken to Jesus to a
high mountain and he was transfigured
before them right so does Mark agree
with
Matthew yes sir okay now let's go to
Luke let's go to Luke now Luke 9 28-35
here we're going to read Luke the lcan
version in its entirety Luke 9 28-35
okay I'm sorry you know what do me a
favor because I skipped 27 add 27 as
well my my apologies Luke 9:27 to 35 uh
to 35 my apologies go
ahead but I tell you truly there is some
standing here who will not taste death
until they see the kingdom of God now
about eight days after these sayings he
took with him Peter and James and John
I'm sorry Peter and John and James and
he went up on the mountain to pray
and as he was praying the appearance of
his face was altered and his clothing
became dazzling white and behold two men
were talking with him Moses and Elijah
who appeared in glory and spoke of his
departure which he was about to
accomplish at Jerusalem now Peter and
those who were with him
were heavy with sleep but when they came
fully awake they saw his glory and the
two men who stood with him and as the
man who were as the men were parting
from him Peter said to Jesus Master it
is good that we are here let us make
three tents one for you one for Moses
and one for Elijah not knowing what he
said as he was saying this things a
cloud came and overshadowed them and
they were afraid as they entered the
cloud and a voice came out of the cloud
saying this is my son My Chosen My
Chosen One listen to him okay is there a
coincidence
Matthew Mark and Luke after recording
Jesus's words where he says there are
some of you standing here who will not
die until they see the kingdom of God
coming in power the son of man coming in
his clean Kingdom and all three of them
say that a week later after Jesus said
that some of them three of them Peter
James and John were taking taken by the
Lord Jesus on a high mountain he
transfigured Before Their Eyes his
clothes became dazzling white more white
than any anyone could bleach them his
face Shone with the glory of the son
Moses and Elijah appear and then God the
Father appears in a cloud the cloud
comes down and they all agree with this
this is also in Mark 9 you'll read it in
verse 7 and Matthew 17 verse four and5
it's all there as the Lord Jesus names
we recall the scriptures perfectly and
sa me saves me from error in Jesus name
and the The Voice they hear the voice in
the cloud the voice of the father say
this is my son whom I love my beloved
Son listen to him is it a coincidence or
are they trying to make you see a
connection with what Jesus said A week
earlier and what took place on the month
of
transfiguration yeah it's obviously yeah
it's obviously like chronological so
what do they want you to see what does
Matthew Mark and Luke want you to see by
the
Transfiguration what do they want you to
see what what are they trying to get you
to see work with me and think about
it uh I think they are trying to uh
communicate that uh the this was the
coming yeah of the son of man yeah you
got it by doing that they're showing you
some of them got to see what Jesus would
look like when he comes in the Kingdom
of his father in his Divine glory
manifested and revealed so some of them
did see what Jesus looks like in his
glorious State and what he'll look like
when he comes in glory and power and
some of them saw
[Music]
it you got it okay now why is your cat
singing see even your cat is praising
you see your cat your cat's praising
she's hungry okay how dare you neglect
your animal
man you want to get her some food and
come
back okay just a second yeah see what a
again he was so excited to get his
question answered he neglected his
animal animal cruelty buddy I'm going to
get you
arrested it's a Transfiguration brother
that's why Matthew Mark and Luke all go
on to record the Transfiguration a week
later right after the Lord Jesus said
those words this is why we have to learn
to read context by the parly spirit as
the Lord Jesus perfects our ability to
understand context and enables me to
recall these passages not forget them
please God and use them to glorify you
in Jesus name it's not a coincidence
every one of the synoptic writers
Matthew Mark and Luke after Jesus says
those words they follow it up
immediately with the
Transfiguration everyone got
it now when the brother returns I'm
going to show him what Peter said about
this ex experience in second Peter
chapter one right so when you're back
brother let me know you back yes I'm
back okay go to Second Peter 1 vers 1618
what does Peter say about the
Transfiguration but second Peter 1 1618
when you get there read it for me what
does Peter say about the
Transfiguration okay second Peter 1:16
for we did not know I'm sorry for we did
not follow cleverly devis mits when we
made known to you the power and coming
of our Lord Jesus Christ but we were
eyewitnesses of his majesty for when he
re received honor and Glory from God the
father son of man coming in glory right
yes remember what Matthew 16:28 you will
see the son of man coming in
glory and his kingdom and his kingdom
glorious right yes yes okay what did
Peter say Peter who was there who saw it
and heard it saw it with his eyes and
heard it with his ears he's recounting
that experience second Peter 1:17 read
that
again for when he received honor and
Glory from God the Father and the voice
was born to him by the Majestic
Glory this is my beloved
Son with whom I am
well 18 we ourselves we ourselves heard
this voice born from heaven for we were
with him on the Holy
Mountain now go back to 16 and pay
attention to that part one more time
16 for we did not follow cleverly
deviced myths when we made known to you
the power and coming of our Lord Jesus
Christ does that sound familiar we were
eyewitnesses do you sound familiar the
power and coming of our Lord Jesus
Christ when we were eyewitnesses of the
majesty and he received honor and Glory
so notice Peter says the Mount of
transfiguration where I saw and others
saw with me James and John and we heard
with our ears
Jesus being transfigured that was when
the Lord Jesus came in power right came
in power coming in power and when he
received honor and Glory
right yes yes did everyone get
it even Peter connects the Mount of
transfiguration with the Fulfillment of
the Lord Jesus's promise that some of
them would not die but see what Jesus
would look like when he comes in power
and in glory so now that you read it
let's go back to Matthew 16:28 let's
reread these Part Parts again Matthew
16:28 truly I say to you there are some
standing here who will not taste death
until they see the son of man coming in
his kingdom and what did Peter say when
we saw right the the coming and the
power of our Lord Jesus Christ the power
and the coming of our Lord Jesus Christ
right yes yes go to Mark 91 one more
time so we're now we're GNA we're going
to read these passages one more time in
light of all that we just discussed Mark
9:1 Mark 91 truly I say to you there are
some standing here who will not taste
death until they see the kingdom of God
after it has come with power wait what
did Peter say the power and coming of
our Lord Jesus Christ right yes right
yes that is that connects and what and
Peter said when did we see our lord
Jesus in power coming in power the power
and coming of our Lord Jesus
Christ was in the mount in the Holy
Mountain you got it so did that answer
your
question yes it answer but uh just the
follow up yes uh because uh in yeah in
27 so this 27 27 has nothing to do now
don't confuse the two 27 has nothing to
do with the amount of transfiguration or
verse 28 what he's saying is the son of
man will come to repay people but that
didn't happen on the Mount of
transfiguration what happened on the
Mount of transfiguration is Jesus giving
them a glimpse of what he will look like
when he comes to repay people for what
they have
earned so they uh the disciples saw him
when what will what he will look like
when yeah because he's not going to come
as a humble Jew born to a humble virgin
Maiden Who as a humble adop the father
who are very poor and just picking up
the trade of his adopted father a
carpenter you know a stonemason just
working day in and day out walking like
the rest of them you know perhaps riding
a horse or a donkey and going that's not
how he's coming when he comes he will
come in the Clouds of heaven with the
host of heaven and great Glory and
Majesty right yes so what did they see
on the Mount of trans congregation not a
humble Jew if you saw him you wouldn't
know that he's God In the Flesh because
he just looks like a Jew they saw him
radiate shining with the glory of the
sun they saw his robe
becoming dazzling white dazzling white
and they saw the Cloud come down with
their eyes and heard the voice of God
the Father with their ears audibly
saying this is my son whom I love and
saw Moses and Elijah that is Glory that
is majestic that is power but only three
of them saw
it so that's why Peter was like was
beside himself trying to altars so but
then when he comes from
Heaven the whole world will see what
only Peter James and John
saw I see right yes the whole world will
see what Peter James and John saw but
just like Jesus said some of you not all
of you and only some did of the 12 only
Peter James and
John and then the
others in fact let me prove to you none
of them saw it and none of them knew
what took place on the mount until after
Jesus's resurrection go to Matthew
17:9 179 yes and as they were coming
down the mountain Jesus commanded them
tell no one the vision until the son of
man is raised from the dead so as long
as Jesus was on Earth until his death
and glorious bodily Resurrection did
anyone else know what took
place no it's only the three and Jesus
Just Like Jesus said only some of you
not all of
you cuz I was trying to uh thank you for
this clarification because I was trying
to read uh you know I'm I was trying to
do my homework about this and I I can't
really understand why it's the
Transfiguration and uh you made it clear
so do you got your answer now I'm trying
I because I'm trying to connect it to
the uh with uh with the destruction of
the temple and it's that's not that
Jesus did come in power and judgment
upon the temple but that's not what he's
talking about because no one saw Jesus
visibly so unless you want to
interpret there are some of you who will
not taste death and you will see so the
seeing means they will see with the
Mind's Eye they will perceive that Jesus
has come in power but not see with his
physical eyes because you can interpret
see means that they will perceive that
when Jerusalem's destroyed that means
Jesus had come in power to destroy
Jerusalem possibly but the reason why
you don't need to take it that far is
because you need to explain why Matthew
Mark and Luke all record the
Transfiguration taking a place about a
week after Jesus said those
words okay why
because it's connected obviously you get
that's the point so why would I want to
find a fulfillment elsewhere when all
three of the writers immediately follow
up what Jesus said with the
Transfiguration yeah so you don't need
to go to like Matthew 24 no this no you
don't there's no there's no need to now
if someone wants to assist to 78 okay
more power too God bless you but I'm
just going with the contextual reading
and don't forget the earliest Greek
copies of the book books of the Bible
the New
Testament there are no chapter divisions
the earliest Greek copies of the New
Testament books they're written in
capital letters no spacing between the
words and no chapter divisions and no
versification and those manuscripts are
called unseals unes or Mages skuls so
when someone's reading Jesus's words in
Matthew 16:28 he doesn't see that
chapter ends and a new chapter begins
because to him it's one continuous
text M making the connection with
Matthew 17 and Matthew 16:28 that much
more
clear the reason why you don't make the
connection is when one chapter ends in
your mind you're conditioned to think
okay this chapter ends the next chapter
is not related because that's how your
mind functions
right yes oh that's unfortunate now what
if I didn't I gave you Matthew
16:17 with no chapter division
yeah I'll just read it as it you would
continue reading to the next right yes
that's right that's how it
is but in the case of Mark 9 and Luke 9
it's in the same
chapter yes it's in the same chapter so
in Mark 9 and Luke 9 it's right there in
the same chapter so you you should make
the connection and not miss it the
reason why you missed it is because you
went to the meean version the version
found in Matthew where there is a
chapter
division okay right yes did I help you
do you have any other questions
or no uh that's yeah you you've
explained it
uh now when do you want me to show you
when Matthew 16:27 will be fulfilled
according to the New
Testament uh sure okay read Matthew
16:27 one more time and I'll show you
when it will be fulfilled according to
Testament for the son of man is going to
come with his angels in the glory of his
father and then he will repay each
person according to what he has done
okay now go to revelation 22 verse 12
and 20 revelation 22 verse 12 and verse
20 revelation
22 behold I am coming soon bringing my
recompense with me to repay each one for
what he has done sound familiar
yes it's okay now read
20 20 he who testifies to these things
says surely I am coming soon amen come
come Lord Jesus now in Revelation
22:20 and 12 according to John when does
Jesus Christ Our Lord come to repay
people according to what they've earned
at the end right yes at the end at the
end when he brings in the new heavens
and the new Earth
right hold on let me ask Timmy Timmy
quing Revelation huh do you want Timmy
to answer or do you want answer for
Timmy no I'll answer for Timmy okay
because revelation 22 is at the end this
is after Jesus has come with the armies
of heaven after he throws the Beast and
the false prophet into the Lake of Fire
after he establishes his Thousand-Year
Reign on Earth and Satan is bound in the
abyss after Satan's released after the
thousand years and then those that He
attempts to make war against the holy
Saints in the holy city are then
consumed by fire after the resurrection
of the dead and they're judged that's
Revelation 20 right Revelation 20
11-5 after the new heavens and new earth
and Jerusalem comes down
right after God joins Jesus on Earth
this is all after that right
yes you got it yes yes okay so according
to John now is it a coincidence John
who's given this Revelation from Jesus
Christ is one of the three that saw
Jesus transfigure on the Mount of
transfiguration I
know so John who was with James and
Peter to see the Lord Jesus transfigure
before his eyes on the Mount of transreg
he is the one who now tells us when
Jesus's words and Matthew 16:27 will be
fulfilled when he comes to establish his
Reign on Earth physically and visibly